ok quindi abbiamo sentito parlare di
blow chain
abbiamo sentito parlare di bitcoin
queste ovviamente sono le mie due
passioni sono quello che adesso faccio
anche di lavoro sono diciamo anche la
mia fissazione e diciamolo pure io
ovviamente sono un tecnico sono un
informatico
provo nasconderlo ma non mi riesce io
sono un nerd tranquilli non è grave ho
fatto i test non sono qui a spiegarvi
perché è meglio programmare in mutande
per codice fluisce da solo non vi farò
un discorso stato tutto quanto di codici
e robe strane e acronimi insomma roba
che va bene in una puntata di big ben
fiori ma per spiegare che cos'è la blow
cena in realtà non funziona è
fondamentalmente perché io adesso faccio
questo di lavoro studio la blow chain
vedo come la si può applicare parlo con
le aziende per fargli vedere come la
possono applicare per trarre dei
vantaggi di solito l'approccio classico
e quello un po diciamo dello dello
spiegone quello che parte dicendo la
blow cei nel registro distribuito su una
rete di computer che gestisce
transazioni una noia mortale
soprattutto non trasmette cos'è
veramente la blow chain non trasmette
quali sono i vantaggi che ci date ci può
portare e non trasmette neanche com'è
che alla fine è diventata la mia
passione è la cosa che mi ha fatto
finalmente scoprire che cosa volevo fare
da grande quindi io parto da questo
parto proprio dallo spiegare come ci
sono arrivando ci sono arrivato dalla
parte sbagliata
io ho cominciato a studiare la veloce in
per dimostrare che non poteva funzionare
perché all'epoca quello che veniva
raccontato sulla blu cena era
obiettivamente troppo era molto
superficiale spezzettato mancavano dei
veri esperti a cui andare a chiedere
queste cose erano praticamente quasi
raggiungibili
oltre che essere nerd quindi l'unica
cosa che potevo fare era quella di dire
questa roba deve avere un buco da
qualche parte perché perché andava
contro le cose che avevo studiato
all'università andava contro dei teoremi
che vengono in piedi informatica che
facciamo tutti quanti giorni quindi il
buco doveva esserci vado lo studio lo
trovo lo racconto al mondo e di questa
cosa non ne parliamo
più mi ci sono voluti più o meno quattro
mesi e mezzo soprattutto di notte perché
allora facevo un altro lavoro e dovevo
cercare informazioni da solo quindi
forum post blog video qualche conferenza
qualche libro ma il problema era siano
tutte informazioni che bisognava
verificare e quindi quindi tirò fuori il
mio super potere da nerd mi metto lì
alla tastiera prova a vedere quello che
viene fuori e tengo solo quello che sta
in piedi
e alla fine di tutto questo percorso
tentativi sono creativi o davanti
finalmente il quadro completo imparato
tutte quelle parole sono riuscito a
metterla insieme e finalmente posso
dichiarare la mia missione fallita
fallita ho perso ha vinto la blow chain
perché studiandole andando a capire
veramente che cosa fa ho detto questa
cosa qui
cambierà il mondo e io non sono uno di
quelli con entusiasmo facile e mia
moglie che mi conosce benissimo dice che
sui cambiamenti e si mismo cosmico però
mi sono trovato quella notte un certo
punto il genoa guarda devo dirti una
cosa ho deciso devo aprire un canale
youtube
devo raccontare la gente come funziona
in maniera semplice e accessibile perché
questa cosa toccherà tutti quindi ci
provono bhutto è andata abbastanza bene
ma che cosa avevo capito che cosa che
avevo visto della blow chain che mi dava
una dimostrazione forte del suo
funzionamento bitcoin c'è questa moneta
nella moneta libera non ci sono stati
che fanno o che possono fare delle leggi
a riguardo non ha una banca centrale e
odio non ha neanche una banca di
rovereta perché volendo la banca
possiamo farla noi sul telefonino non
sto parlando di una web app di una banca
che si appoggia al vostro no no no la
banca
il telefonino voi immaginate che cosa
vuol dire questo per quelle decine di
migliaia di famiglie in giro per il
mondo che non hanno nessun accesso a
nessun servizio bancario o finanziario
motivo per cui oxfam che è
un'associazione non governativa che
combatte appunto la povertà e la
differenza sta sviluppando proprio dei
progetti in blow chain con delle valute
tipo simili a bitcoin perché è più
immediato perché è più facile perché
funziona
e qui stata la domanda come fa
funzionare come fa a essere sicuro se
non c'è dietro una banca vi do qualche
dato la rete di bitcoin a contenuto e ha
protetto l'equivalente di 810 miliardi
di dollari al suo massimo e non è mai
stato possibile rubare un solo centesimo
e non che non ci abbiano provato è la
rete di bitcoin è distribuita in tutto
il mondo vuol dire che può letteralmente
sostenere degli attacchi nucleari e
quelle cosine carine tipo blocco del
conto corrente limita il prelievo tipo
argentina o grecia o blocco del com non
si possono fare peccato no peccato no
anzi mi piace un sacco questa cosa qua
diciamo che allora forse bitcoin è più
sicuro della vostra banca
ok ma a parte la moneta che cosa si può
fare
possiamo provare ad applicarla ad
esempio alla filiera del cibo sapere
vita morte e miracoli di un prodotto
prima di comprarlo con quali ingredienti
e fatto se contiene degli allergeni
quali sono gli impegni vincolanti che il
produttore si prende col consumatore
immaginate questo cosa vuol dire ad
esempio per il made in italy per
combattere gli italian sounding o
immaginate che invece di usarlo per il
cibo lo usiamo per i farmaci dove c'è un
problema di contraffazione notevole rila
contraffazione vuol dire poter morire
oppure ci sono già delle polizze
assicurative che lavorano esclusivamente
per cui io posso ad esempio assicurare
il mio volo aereo se arriva ad un
ritardo invece di arrabbiarmi quando
sono lì sulla scaletta che sto scendendo
dall'aereo
accendo il telefono lo guardo pac il
pagamento dell'assicurazione già
arrivato ah no scusate non c'è di mezzo
un assicurazione
basta laboccetta che abbastanza
trasparente fa da sola questo è
fantastico ovviamente se non siete un
assicuratore e infatti banche
assicurazioni consorzi stanno
cominciando a guardare dentro questa
cosa per non farsi lasciare indietro
però diciamo che siccome lo fanno
diciamo battendo delle basi diverse
degli scopi diversi
diciamo che è meglio l'originale della
coppia
ma com'è possibile tutto questo diciamo
che la funzione principale della blue
scena è quella di disintermediare cioè
noi usiamo degli intermediari adesso
perché fondamentalmente su un'unica cosa
che possiamo appoggiarci quando dobbiamo
fare uno scambio una figura intermedia
che garantisca sia me che la mia
controparte lab lo sheikh toglie questo
elemento di mezzo in realtà la blow
chain toglie la necessità di fidarsi
perché si fa carico lei di tutto questo
in maniera ferrea
questo se ci pensiamo rende
immediatamente obsoleto ogni sistema che
abbiamo di trasferiti verso le
informazioni fra le persone e com'è
possibile tutto questo è la blow cena è
fatta da una serie di elementi che sono
un po come dei gli ingranaggi da dove
vengono
vengono da parti diverse del sapere
umano molto scorrelate fra di loro c'è
di mezzo matematica informatica economia
economia politica sociologia e una serie
di altre cose e tutte quanti vengono
messe insieme a funzionare in maniera
perfetta come un orologio ma sapete qual
è il bello per certi versi la beffa
tutti questi ingranaggi noi ce l'abbiamo
già 20 30 anni fa cioè labbro cena è
datata 2008 ma noi potevamo
tranquillamente aver celato nel 1990
dalla monnezza cosa mancava mancavano
delle idee geniali per usare questi
pezzi e metterle insieme per farli
funzionare insieme e quali sono queste
generali
secondo me la prima è ribaltiamo
completamente il punto di vista ci sono
stati dei tentativi di fare qualche cosa
di simile a bit coni all'abruzzo in
prima ma sono tutti quanti falliti per
un motivo si focalizzavano sul bene
virtuale sulla merce virtuale sul
dollaro digitale il problema di queste
informazioni digitali e che io vado a
casa con il copia incolla o una zecca
casa diventa milionario inflazione del
sistema il sistema crolla quindi non
funziona la veloce ma allora che cosa fa
ribalta l'oggetto su cui va mettere
l'attenzione non guarda più l'oggetto ma
la transazione cioè lo spostamento di un
oggetto dal precedente proprietario al
successivo proprietario questo mi
permette di fare esattamente tutte le
stesse operazioni di prima ma ho
cambiato la natura dell'informazione e
quindi avendo cambiato la natura
dell'informazione cambia il modo di
gestirla ad esempio idea geniale numero
due
cambia il modo di proteggerla mentre
prima la informazione noi eravamo
abituati a proteggerla nascondendola
tenendola
cifrando la roba mia non guardare quando
si tratta di una transazione il modo
migliore per proteggere invece di
divulgarla avete presente in compagnia
quel classico amico che si dimentica
sempre che i 10 euro gliele avevate già
a dati ed alla volta dopo cosa fate
ragazzi testimoni tutti è ok è
esattamente la stessa cosa
l'informazione pubblica e quella forte
perché quella che conosciamo tutti
poi su cui poi non ci possono venire a
dir bugie quindi quello che prima era un
elemento di debolezza
l'abbiamo fatto diventare un elemento di
forza perché abbiamo una comunità con
cui condividere con l'informazione e qui
idea geniale numero 3
ci serve la comunità abbiamo un insieme
di persone che volontariamente a
sostiene lavoro cella tiene in piedi la
fa funzionare
e come ogni comunità si basa su un
insieme di regole
la prima la più importante di tutte
quella che dice siamo tutti uguali tutti
possiamo avere accesso alle stesse
informazioni tutti possiamo vedere tutti
questi ci fa sì che siamo responsabili
delle informazioni che vediamo le
possiamo andare a controllare e se non
ci torno a qualche cosa le scartiamo
queste sono le predette regole win win
perché io posso fare il mio interesse
sulla bruxelles
ovvio ma nel farlo e per farlo devo fare
anche l'interesse di tutta quanta la
collettività e quindi ci diamo forza
l'un l'altro
un altro effetto di queste regole molto
particolare non si può imparare
potresti provarci al problema è che è
costato al mente tanto è talmente
improbabile che tu ci riesca o
soprattutto è così eclatante che se ne
accorgono tutti che alla fine sostanza
non conviene quindi in un certo senso la
blow cenci costringe all'onestà alla
trasparenza e come facciamo ad avere un
sistema di regole così aperto chiaro ma
ferreo da addirittura invece essere
trasparenti e onesti
usiamo la matematica ma attenzione un
pezzo la crittografia
ma attenzione un pezzo non quella che
usano le spie per passaggi messaggi di
nascosto dicendo senza
l'informazione deve essere pubblica
usiamo con la parte della fotografia che
ci serve per capire ci ha messo un
informazione in maniera non rifiutabile
e per controllare che poi nel tempo
quell'informazione non sia cambiata
l'equivalente di quello che facciamo con
la firma digitale
lei però in modalità un po più smart se
vogliamo poi ci sarebbero l'idea geniale
numero 5 numero 6 numero 7 numero però
insomma comincerei a tirar fuori tutte
le cose da nerd che avevo promesso di
non parlare è tendenzialmente questo un
po fa già però capire qual è la portata
della veloce né su quali idee si basa
c'è un problema
queste idee sono per certi versi anche
un po il tallone d'achille della
bruxelles per noi
l'intelligenza umana perché ci chiede
fondamentalmente di ribaltare il tipo di
informazione cambiare il modo in cui la
gestisce fare delle cose che non ci
vengono spontanee
questo è difficile da accettare per
certi versi perché vuol dire mettere in
discussione delle cose che magari per
noi sono fondamentali su cui magari ci
basiamo esempio classico quando ti
vengono a chiedere ma sti bitcoin sono
soldi veri e di parte la domanda la
risposta provocativa che già pronta
perché gli altri sono soldi veri
cosa vuol dire essere soldi veri e se
sono soldi veri a cosa serve una legge
che impone a tutti quanti di accettarli
come forma di pagamento
partono delle discussioni che durano ore
e birre ma il punto non è capire chi dei
due abbia ragione ma capire a che cosa
che costringe a pensare la volo cento e
che cosa devi mettere in discussione e
mettere in discussione degli assunti e
difficile ci chiede praticamente di
uscire dalla nostra con force one e di
rinunciare a certi abitudini certe cose
che diamo per scontate che magari non è
che sono vere o sono normali come
sono semplicemente abitudinarie e quando
incomincia mettere in discussione magari
ti viene fuori il guizzo per dire c'è un
altro modo per farlo magari addirittura
migliore quindi vale la pena uscire
fuori da questa con force on
ovviamente sì almeno da parte mia perché
immaginate che già adesso sarebbe
possibile fare un sistema basato sulla
bruxelles che ci permette di tracciare
ogni singolo euro recuperato con gettito
fiscale per andare a sapere dove viene
speso su questa tecnica qua non c'è
ovviamente di altre difficoltà che
stiamo parlando
ok oppure di avere un sistema di voto
elettorale basato su bracciano
non si può ancora fare è difficilissimo
però ci stanno lavorando in tanti perché
perché immaginati come potrebbe essere
un sistema di voto elettorale è basato
sulla brace inclusivo tutti gli aventi
diritto al voto possono votare
verificabile
io posso controllare che il mio voto è
andato esattamente la forza politica
curio designato che è stato conteggiato
ma contemporaneamente proteggere la mia
privacy
quindi il mio voto rimane segreto e non
posso barare
non posso usare le informazioni che ho
per fare ad esempio cose tipo il voto di
scambio
avete presente questo che cosa vuol dire
per tutte le democrazie le simil
democrazia che ci sono in giro per il
mondo
quando il ministro dicevo questa cosa
cambierà il mondo mica scherzavo
e a queste cose quasi mi riferivo però
bisogna fare questo sforzo
e allora bisogna ribaltare le idee
ribaltiamo le le idee perché a ribaltare
le idee comunque il primo passo
fondamentale imprescindibile per
ribaltare il mondo
o magari un suo pezzettino e una volta
che l'abbiamo ribaltato magari lo
possiamo ridisegnare lo possiamo
ripensare tutti insieme magari proprio
sugli elementi fondanti della bruxelles
perché in fondo tutti quanti vorremmo un
mondo che sia inclusivo più trasparente
e verificabile dove non si può varare è
più sicuro
[Applauso]